The following statement
is utterly ludicrous.
It is also true.
The world's most important
advanced technology
is nearly all produced
in a single facility.
What's more, that facility is located
in one of the most geopolitically
fraught areas on Earth,
an area in which many analysts believe
that war is inevitable within the decade.
The future of artificial intelligence
hangs in the balance.
The Taiwan Semiconductor
Manufacturing Company,
or TSMC,
makes all of the world's
most-advanced AI chips.
This includes Nvidia's GPUs,
Google's TPUs, AMD's GPUs,
the AI chips for Microsoft, Amazon, Tesla,
Cerebrus, SambaNova
and every other credible competitor.
Modern artificial intelligence
simply would not be possible
without these highly specialized chips.
Little wonder, then,
that Time magazine recently
described TSMC as,
"The world's most important company
that you've probably never heard of."
Nvidia CEO Jensen Huang
put it more colorfully,
saying, “Basically,
there is air ... and TSMC.”
(Laughter)
TSMC's chip fabrication
facilities, or fabs,
the buildings where chips
are physically built,
is located on the western coast of Taiwan,
a mere 110 miles from mainland China.
In this map, Taiwan is shown in orange
and China is shown in green.
Today, China and Taiwan
are nearer to the brink of war
than they have been in decades.
Many policymakers in Washington predict
that China will invade Taiwan
within the next five years.
A China-Taiwan conflict
would be devastating
for many reasons.
Aside from the heavy human toll,
one underappreciated consequence
is that it would paralyze
the global AI ecosystem.
Put simply, the entire field
of artificial intelligence
faces an astonishingly precarious
single point of failure in Taiwan.
Amid all of the fervor around AI today,
this fact is not widely
enough appreciated.
If you are working on
or are interested in AI,
you need to be paying attention.
How did we get here
and what can we do about it?
Let's start with a brief, whirlwind
overview of the chip industry.
Semiconductors, or chips,
are the most complex object in the world
that humanity knows how to mass-produce.
Making semiconductors requires
the world's purest metals,
the world's most expensive machinery,
legions of highly specialized engineers
and atom-level manufacturing precision.
It is important to distinguish between two
different types of chip companies.
First, fabless chip makers,
which design but do not
manufacture their own chips.
And second, foundries,
which manufacture chips
designed by other companies.
Almost every well-known chip
company today is fabless,
from Nvidia to AMD to Qualcomm.
These companies do not
produce their own chips.
Instead, they design chips,
and then they rely on foundries like TSMC
to actually manufacture
those chips for them.
There are only three companies
in the world today
that are capable of manufacturing chips
anywhere near the leading edge
of semiconductor technology:
TSMC, Samsung and Intel.
Of those three,
only one can reliably produce
the world's most advanced AI chips,
including chips like Nvidia's H100 GPUs.
That one company is TSMC.
As of this morning,
TSMC's market capitalization
was 470 billion dollars,
making it the 13th-largest
company in the world,
larger than ExxonMobil,
JPMorgan Chase or Walmart.
How has TSMC become such a dominant force?
The short answer is that powerful
economies of scale
exist in the world of chip fabrication,
leading inexorably
to winner-take-all dynamics.
Making advanced semiconductors
requires tremendous upfront
and ongoing capital expenditure.
In 2021, TSMC announced
that it would invest 100 billion dollars
over the next three years
to continue expanding
its fabrication capabilities.
No other company in the world
can justify that level of investment.
TSMC can, because of the sheer volume
of chips that it produces,
far more than any other
company in the world.
A related dynamic that helps explain
TSMC's unassailable position
is what has come to be known
as the TSMC Grand Alliance.
TSMC has invested heavily over decades
to develop deep partnerships
with dozens of companies
across the semiconductor supply chain,
from software providers like Cadence
to equipment manufacturers like ASML
to chip designers like Nvidia.
In turn, these companies
have developed their own products
in accordance with TSMC's road map,
leading to powerful lock-in.
In summary, a combination
of economies of scale, network effects,
and unrivaled specialization
have made TSMC irreplaceable
and have made the entire world deeply,
precariously dependent upon it.
This brings us to the present,
delicate geopolitical moment.
Last October,
the Biden administration
took the dramatic step
of banning the export of all high-end
AI chips to any entity in China.
The rationale behind
these measures was clear.
To leverage US control
of the global semiconductor supply chain
as a choke point to handicap
China's AI capabilities.
The US government is currently formulating
expansions to this policy.
At the same time, the US is taking steps
to reduce its reliance
on chip fabrication facilities
located in East Asia.
In late 2022,
TSMC announced that it would
invest 40 billion dollars
to build two new state-of-the-art fabs
in the United States, in Arizona.
The first of these two fabs is slated
to begin production in 2025.
Bringing advanced
chip production to US soil
will help mitigate the AI industry's
absolute dependence on Taiwan-based fabs.
But the Arizona fabs
will not solve everything.
Their production capacity will be modest,
representing less than five percent
of TSMC's total global output.
And the most advanced semiconductor
production capabilities
and technologies will remain in Taiwan.
So where might things go from here?
Let's briefly consider
a few possibilities
on this three-dimensional chessboard.
Let's start with optimistic scenario.
Taiwan's central role in the global
semiconductor industry
is often referred to
as its “silicon shield.”
The basic theory is this:
because China depends so heavily on Taiwan
for the chips that it needs
to keep its own economy running,
China will stop short of invading Taiwan
and putting TSMC's production at risk.
And because the rest of the world
is likewise so dependent on TSMC,
the United States and other powers
will go to great lengths
to protect the island
and defend its sovereignty.
Under this theory,
while China may continue
to build out its military
and engage in cross-strait saber-rattling,
it will stop short of kinetic
action against Taiwan.
But the silicon shield is just a theory,
not a guarantee.
What would happen if China
were to move decisively to retake Taiwan?
TSMC's fabs would almost certainly
be rendered inoperative.
It is conceivable that the Taiwanese,
or even the US military,
would preemptively destroy the fabs
in order to prevent the CCP
from taking control of this
valuable strategic resource.
Even if the physical buildings
were to remain undamaged
after a Chinese invasion,
it is unrealistic that the CCP would be
able to continue operating the fabs
to produce cutting-edge chips.
Keeping leading edge fabs running
requires ongoing and deep partnership
with organizations across the global
semiconductor ecosystem,
as well as a steady inflow of materials,
equipment and services.
These would be denied
to an invading power.
Let me say this one more time:
if or when China invades Taiwan,
TSMC's fabs will,
in all likelihood, go offline.
This will mean that no more Nvidia H100s
or any other cutting-edge AI chips
will be able to be produced
anywhere in the world.
What would this mean for the world of AI?
After TSMC, the company
best positioned to step up
and produce cutting-edge
AI chips is Samsung.
Samsung is currently the only company
in the world, other than TSMC,
that is capable of producing
three-nanometer chips,
today's cutting-edge technology.
But Samsung's production capabilities
are far inferior to TSMC's today.
In a best-case scenario,
it would take Samsung years to scale up
to TSMC's current AI
chip yields and volumes.
This brings us to America's
former chip champion, Intel.
It was hardly a decade ago
that Intel's chip-manufacturing
capabilities were the envy of the world.
But in recent years,
Intel has fallen behind.
The company struggled mightily
in its transition to both ten-nanometer
and seven-nanometer node technologies,
even resorting to outsourcing some
of its leading edge production to TSMC.
Under CEO Pat Gelsinger,
Intel aspires to regain
its chipmaking supremacy
with an ambitious plan to leapfrog TSMC
and begin producing
two-nanometer chips in 2024.
Whether this ambitious plan will actually
prove achievable, however,
remains to be seen.
Before we despair too much,
let us note a couple encouraging points.
First, keep in mind that a considerable
stock of AI chips already exists
in the world.
And even in a worst-case scenario,
these chips would remain in use.
Second, while the most advanced AI chips,
like Google’s TPUs or Nvidia’s H100s,
can only be manufactured in Taiwan,
there are many fabs around the world,
from the US to Europe to Israel,
that are capable of producing
lagging-edge logic chips at scale.
Though they are far less powerful
than today's leading AI chips,
these previous-generation chips
could be used in a pinch
to support some AI computing workloads.
Ultimately, though, it would be
devastating for humanity
to lose its ability to produce the chips
that power today's cutting-edge
artificial intelligence.
Progress in AI would be
profoundly disrupted.
Let us hope that diplomacy prevails.
(Applause)